sie gilt als eine der besten first
classes der Welt unter Kennern auch
gerne als die Nummer 1 der Service und
die Schweizer Qualität sollen einfach
perfekt sein First Class Flüge sind zwar
immer extrem teuer hier hätte ich aber
sogar knapp 15 000 € bezahlt nun wünsche
ich euch ganz viel Spaß mit meinem
zweiten First Class Test in 19 Stunden
von Tokio nach Zürich und weiter nach
Berlin und damit jo Leute was geht ab
einen wunderschönen guten Morgen aus
Tokio in Japan ich befinde mich gerade
noch in meinem Hotel hier checke aber
jetzt gleich aus und es geht zum
Flughafen Leute ich fliege heute zum
ersten Mal in meinem Swiss first CL und
ich glaube das wird ein ganz besonderer
und coolter Tag wir sind 18 Stunden
unterwegs ich würde sagen gar nicht
lange labern auf geht's ich werde jetzt
gleich abgeholt ihr fahrt wie ich den
Flug gebucht habe wie teuer eigentlich
ist das wird ein verdammt geiles Video
ich bin richtig hyped let's go auch ein
fantastisches Hotel hier aber die Zeit
in Toko ist vorbei okay ausgecheckt ab
dem Aufzug das ist Jonas den habt ihr
vielleicht nee das ist jetzt das erste
Video wo die dich sehen auf jeden Fall
fliegen wir zusammen zurück Transfer
jetzt von hier aus zum Flughafen
eigentlich würden wir einhalb Stunden
mit dem Auto fahren aber wir haben uns
was anderes überlegt das Ding ist fürs
Video wird sicherlich cool und ich freue
mich da sehr drauf dieser Tag wird
glaube ich absolut next level viel Spaß
mit diesem geilen
[Musik]
Video zweite Mal in meinem Leben First
Class das erste Mal war ja mit Emirates
ich bin heute echt mal gespannt du
meinst es geil ne ich find sie sehr sehr
gut hello gen
[Musik]
morning
than you
by junge wie lustig ich bin noch nie in
meinem Leben so ein Ding geflogen er mal
Helikopter in meinem Leben kan ich mal
die
ja ich bin echt gespannt ich habe ein
bisschen Angst ja es war be meinem
ersten Mal auch so also keine Sorge mir
echt günstigen Helikopter geschossen
deswegen dachte ich mir ich bau das
einfach mit ins Video ein auf geht zum
Flughafen ab geht's nach Deutschland ich
freue mich
Name
[Musik]
[Applaus]
okay
[Musik]
so war ultra geil vor allem so schnell
auf hinweg habe ich z Stunden gebraucht
wir jetzt 20 gebraucht könnte man sich
dran gewöhnen geiler Flug sind noch
einmal komplett über tok geflogen jetzt
s direkt am flughafenar ü
[Musik]
Rollfeld
bye
by kurz Werbung in eigener Sache ich
habe mir eine Fotokamera zugelegt und
mache auf allen meinen Reisen jetzt
immer ein paar Fotos die ich dann als
Recap auf meinem Instagram Alex wie
poste ich glaube das wissen viele von
euch gar nicht ich würde mich echt über
Support freuen deswegen Check da gerne
mal rein und da bekommt ihr natürlich
auch viel früher mit wo ich so Hinreise
okay wir sind da Narita International
Airport das ist hier einer von zwei
Flughäfen in Tokio und von hier aus
geht's jetzt weiter war auf jeden Fall
super entspannt der Transfer hier hin
werde ich nie vergessen geiles Erlebnis
und ja jetzt freue ich mich auf den Flug
ca 18 Stunden von hier geht's nach
Zürich und von Zürich dann weiter nach
Berlin erste Mal in meinem Leben Swiss
ich bin glaube ich an economy bin ich
schon mal mit den geflogen sind wir
direkt richtig oder Swiss Ana sweet
Checkin First Class ja
hallo so private Sicherheitskontrolle
nicht filmen nachdem wir dann durch den
Security Check gegangen sind haben wir
eine Ansprechpartnerin bekommen die hat
uns dann einmal komplett durch die
Passkontrolle geführt und uns einmal so
ein bisschen den Flughafen gezeigt und
dann auch den direkten Weg zur Ana sweet
Lounge aka Ana First Class Lounge da
konnen wir erstmal reingehen und ein
bisschen rumhängen thank you danke Anna
sweet Lounge aha
hallo thank
you hallo morning Nudelbar jetzt erstmal
paar Nudeln oder was
könnte schlechter sein Okay Leute
angekommen in der ANA Suet Lounge ich
glaube die ist nur für First Class Gäste
das Angebot hier ist klein aber sehr
sehr fein ich habe mir hier so ein
bisschen ja was zum Frühstück geholt ich
hatte heute morgen im Hotel noch nichts
wieso ist so ein Burger wenn ich fragen
darf ja ist ja auch schon 10 Uhr na hier
gibt's auf jeden Fall jede Menge kleine
Leckereien viele Snacks ich habe da
hinten einiges gesehen ich Filme Euch
das einmal ab dann könnt ihr mal gucken
so kann man noch starten Tag beginnt gut
guten Appetit kannst Du mir noch mal den
Burger zeigen einmal hier m schmecken
Burger ohne alles wie
schmeckt okay eine blette Zwiebeln drin
Alter so noch kurzer toilettencheck so
sieht's hier aus ja wir gehen mal weiter
zu den
Duschen take Look
okay okay thank
you ja okay jetzt haben wir die Duschen
auch noch
gesehen nicht spektakulär aber ist geil
bra nicht duschen hab eben noch geduscht
hier hat man auch noch so kleine
einzugkabinen sieht aus eigentlich wie
ein Flugzeug hier riecht's nur wie in
Thailand bei der Fußmassage na ja wir
haben jetzt auf jeden Fall Boarding noch
ganz interessant hier in dieser riesen
Lounge sind gerade nur vier Gäste von
Swiss anscheinend fliegt gar kein
anderes Flugzeug aber hier sind so viele
Mitarbeiter es ist so verrückt wirklich
also das ist wieder noch mal eine ganz
neue Erfahrung für mich selber auf
diesem Level zu reisen na ja jetzt
schauen wir mal wie es so weiter geht
wir haben ungefähr eineinhalb Stunden in
der Lounge verbracht und wurden dann von
diesen beiden netten Herren abgeholt die
uns dann quer unterhalb des Narita
airpods durchgeführt haben direkt zum
Gate also wir mussten nicht durch Duty
Free hatten keinen langen Weg das ging
echt schnell obwohl das Gate gar nicht
mal so n dran war das war wirklich cool
und absoluter Service natürlich
ne by
by bye byk mein Gott das ist hier aber
auch alles was ist
das
[Applaus]
danke
schönes oben Ken wir hab lang
FL wenn Sie wollen
später
nicht Jonas trink Orang was für
Saft schauen wir später mal rein es ist
halt anders moderner als emates firstass
in der ich mitgeflogen bin sehr
gern danke schön
B
okay mittlerweile angekommen ich muss
sagen er ein super üb Platz bisschen
andersem die neue emlich sit alles
ziemlich modern aus wir fliegen jetzt 14
Stunden nach Zürich also echt ziemlich
lange das ist der längste Flug auf dem
ich war schauen wir mal wie schnell
dasgt ganzen Komfor hier sicherlich
schnell
[Musik]
also
ne geschüttelt
los ging es mit einem Gruß aus der Küche
das waren so ein paar knusperstangen mit
Thunfisch und Paprika und Tomaten glaube
ich ich weiß es nicht mehr ganz genau
war auf jeden Fall sehr sehr lecker und
ein netter
[Musik]
Willkommensgruß junge ich lache mich
kaputt dass das so hier wird das hätte
ich nicht gedacht jetzt habe ich den
Vogel auch noch die ganze Zeit hier vor
mir
sitzen so wir haben uns jetzt hier zweit
hingesetzt um gemeinsam zu speisen ich
wusste nicht dass es sowas gibt in
irgendeinem Flugzeug ich dachte das geht
nicht aber das bietet sich hier
natürlich an deswegen umso lustiger es
gibt auf jeden Fall jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen Brot und ich habe mir bestellt
ich hätte erstmal fünf Vorspeisen nehmen
können habe ich natürlich nicht es gibt
erstmal Lachsfilet dann gibt's Spinat
Brokkoli Rahmsuppe mit Kräuter
Mascarpone und salbebaguette und
saisonsalat mit Radieschen und Knoblauch
coutons als Hauptgang habe ich
grilliertes rinfil mit madeaderasauß
direkt von unge Kartoffelpüree kurz den
Witz geklaut Kartoffelpüree sautierter
Rosenkohl und so weiter und so for und
dann gibt's Käse eine Käseplatte das ist
ja auch immer beliebt in Flugzeugen ne
es gibt immer Käseplatten und als
Dessert dunkler Schokoladen
Orangenkuchen mit beerenkulis und dann
fall ich tot um weil ich zu viel
gegessen habe und die haben uns auch
Angeboten raklett zu du hast raklett
bestellt okay und Jonas hat tatsächlich
das raklett bestellt das wusste ich gar
nicht da bin ich mal gespannt ich habe
es nicht genommen erster Eindruck super
okay wir starten mit der ersten
Vorspeise wir haben hier BIK Lachs wie
heißt es weiß auch nicht halt Lachs
probieren wir mal ich bin jetzt nicht so
der Mega Lachs Liebhaber aber wird schon
das hier ist übrigens mein WiFi Code mal
gucken wie gut das Internet hier oben
ist so der Lachs mit ein bisschen
metigch nee was war das ja natürlich
schon geil lecker würde ich im
Restaurant nicht bestellen aber
allererste
[Musik]
Sahne okay weiter geht's mit der Suppe
sieht auch schon wieder geil aus wir
haben beide die gleiche Suppe ja würde
ich sagen lass wir uns mal schmecken ist
das bei anderen airlin auch so dass die
Teller so groß nein
ne verrückt also ist wirklich wie im
also auch der Tisch ist
riesig boah bin gar nicht so ein
Brokkoli Fan aber ist schon lecker
weiter geht's mit einem saisonsalat mit
croissons
cotons so probieren wir mal ja seh
lecker schön
knackig ne ist lecker ist halt ein Salat
ne hatte schon bessere Salate im
Flugzeug aber der ist okay keine Frage
der ist nicht schlecht mir ist ein
bisschen zu bitter ich muss kurz pinkeln
und wir nutzen das mal um uns die
Toilette anzuschauen man hat hier auf
jeden Fall genug Platz ein Spiegel da
ein Spiegel hinter mir ja an sich was
ist das hier repair face Serum und das
wahrscheinlich noch mal al so handcrem
ist halt einfach eine ganz normale
Toilette der Service hier ist wirklich
klasse Komfort auch es ist halt einfach
nicht so prunkvoll würde ich sagen aber
das ist gar nicht schlimm finde ich gar
nicht schlimm wie bei Emir z.B jetzt
gleich kommt der Hauptgang bin ich mal
gespannt und dann muss ich mein Video
schneiden schinkansen Video check das ab
das ist längst schon
online so Leute der Hauptgang ist da wir
haben hier Steak mit Kartoffel P und so
ein paar veggetaes ich bin mal gespannt
ich habe jetzt schon viele Steaks im
Flugzeug probiert wie das hier schmeckt
al ist gut ich muss sagen schmeckt
besser als es aussieht sieht so hell aus
kartoffelpure
dazu also ich muss sogar tatsächlich
sagen wir haben jetzt noch ein bisschen
Gemüse dazu bekommen das ist das beste
Steak was ich je im Flugzeug hatte
besser als das bei Emirates Daumen nach
oben fürs was sagst du zu deinem
racklet sehr sehr
lecker und dazu habe ich mir jetzt ein
Wein hier genehmigt das ist ein Chardon
ich will heute eigentlich gar nichts auf
diesem Flug Trinken habe ich beim
letzten mal
übertrieben oder ich sag mal ich wurde
dazu verleitet ist auf jeden Fall ganz
lecker ich bin jetzt nicht so der
Weintrinker
aber muss ich ja wenigstens einmal fürs
Video bestellen ne ein nehme ich
[Musik]
noch haben wir hier noch eine
zauberhafte Käseplatte ganz schön viel
Käse für die
käsefreunde ich bin auch erst so seitdem
ich 17 18 bin dass ich diese käsedinger
mag wo oben so ein Käse ist und da
drüber dann noch so eine
Weintraube früher mochte ich das nicht
jetzt finde ich ganz lecker und zu guter
Letzt haben wir hier noch diesen
wunderbaren Schokokuchen und ich habe es
euch eben schon vorgelesen aber ich habe
vergessen was es war K wir schau noch
mal eben nach Heidelbeer Aprikosen Tate
ususu sorb und Himbeersoße ja habe ich
mir doch schon fast gedacht das ist was
ist
bombastisch schon wild ne also
kulinarisch hier bei Swiss vom Feinsten
muss man wirklich
[Musik]
sagen okay Leute ich habe jetzt in Ruhe
aufgegessen und ihr seht schon es ist
ziemlich dunkel geworden irgendwie
schlafen alle Japan haben wir jetzt
schon 16:30 Uhr in Deutschland müsste
8:30 Uhr sein und jetzt schaut mal ich
habe Glück weil neben mir sitzt keiner
und die meinten jetzt zu mir hey kein
Problem hier kannst du dein Laptop
hinstellen und so gesehen bisschen
weiter an meinem Video schneiden und da
kann ich schlafen was bedeutet ich habe
jetzt eigentlich zwei Kabinen für mich
und das ist extrem geil ja okay hatte
ich damals bei Emirates auch weil ich da
der einzige war aber da haben die mein
Bett nicht woanders positioniert und
hier hat man halt noch mal mehr Platz
deswegen würde ich sagen nehmen wir mal
Schlafanzug und manity Kit mit rüber
okay bis
später ist das geil
machen also das ist wirklich so ein
Luxus es ist unfassbar und ich freue
mich echt so sehr darüber dass ich das
hin und wieder mal genießen darf um
darüber ein Video zu drehen mal gucken
welche first classes noch so kommen
jetzt ziehe ich mich mal kurz um oh hier
war so eine schöne Schleife rumgebunden
die habe ich jetzt einfach mal abgemacht
so Schlafanzug ist auch an die Hose
ziehe ich glaube ich nicht an die
brauche ich nicht es ist halt wirklich
wie ein Bett man hat hier richtig dicke
Kissen man hat richtig man hat eine
richtig dicke Matratze für ein Flugzeug
man hat eine Bettdecke die ist richtig
kuschlig und hier bei swis muss ich auf
jeden Fall sagen die First Class ist
noch mal deutlich krasser als die
Business Class ich bin da gerade einmal
durchgegangen bei Emirat z.B fand ich
den Unterschied gar nicht so krass also
es gibt natürlich einen aber aber hier
ist noch mal viel gewaltiger schauen wir
mal ins amenity Kit vielleicht kann ich
davon ja noch irgendwas gebrauchen Swiss
first steht hier drauf wir haben h
einmal eine Zahnbürste mit lmax
natürlich noch mal elmax hier haben wir
Handcreme eine Schlafmaske und Socken
brauche ich hier gar nicht es ist eh so
krass dunkel Rola Bonbons vanity Kit
keine Ahnung ein ach so genau hier
gibt's keine Tücher die so heiß sind die
man ins Gesicht macht wie bei Thai
Emirates Qatar und so weiter
Gesichtscreme ist jetzt nichts mega
wertvolles dabei aber trotzdem ganz nett
und das kann man ja mitnehmen ich mache
jetzt erstmal kurz die Augen zu bisschen
ausholen und dann setze ich mich an
Laptop bis
[Musik]
[Applaus]
später
[Musik]
für mich gibt's jetzt das zweite Mal
Essen man kann ja eigentlich so viel
bestellen bis die hauptgänger
aufgebraucht sind aber es ist noch
ziemlich viel da und es gab gerade auch
Snackkarte mit Burger Caesar Salad also
eigentlich völlig crazy ich habe mir
jetzt hier auch mal dieses R bestellt
und wir schauen mal kurz
raus wow das sind ja süße Wolken was
sind das da für Berge wir sind gerade in
aerbeidschan alter eigentlich fliegen
wir von der dunkel weg aber werden
gleich
[Musik]
eingeholt ich habe mich dann drei
Stunden vor der Landung auch mal dem
Entertainment Zubehör gewidmet man
bekommt auf jeden Fall Kopfhörer
allerdings soweit ich weiß keine neus
canceling Kopfhörer das fand ich nicht
so gut weil das Rauschen im Flugzeug
natürlich schon ziemlich stark ist und
wenn man dann schon so einen hohen Preis
bezahlt finde ich sollten vernünftige
neues kenceling Kopfhörer schon drin
sein was ich cool fand ist gab viele
Dokumentation über die Schweiz und
irgendwie Schweizer Filme aber natürlich
auch jede Menge internationaler Filme
irgendwelche Klassiker ich habe mir ein
bisschen was angeschaut aber war auch
froh als der Bildschirm wieder aus war
weil ich vorher schon lange genug auf
meinen Laptop gestartrt habe man bekommt
auf jeden Fall einiges geboten der
Umfang war z.B bei Emirates oder Qatar
aber noch
[Musik]
größer
meine Herren schön dass Sie hier sind
schön dass Sie da sind ich fahre jetzt
qu jetzt zum Hauptgebäude rüber und sie
wissen vielleicht wie es funktioniert
wenn sie jetzt Anschluss Flüge haben
dann so wir wollen jetzt hier durch ein
Security Check geschickt da war niemand
außer wir und jetzt sind wir hier in
eine First Class Lounge Swiss ich konnte
nicht mehr Film ich bin h so voll
gepackt sieht auf jeden Fall ganz nett
aus ist riesig in
Zürich
uiuiui hallo erstmal was essen oder
haben wir ja auch so lange nicht wir
sind ja auf jeden Fall jetzt in Zürich
in der firstass Lounge und ich habe euch
ja gesagt ich muss euch noch erklären
wie ich diesen Flug gebucht habe bzw
nicht ich aber eigentlich kostet der
Flug halt 15000 € und hier neben wir
haben wir jetzt den Experten Jonas der
erklärt das jetzt mal kurz weil Swiss
First Class kann man nur buchen mit
Meilen wenn man Senator ist genau also
die Swiss first kann man mit Meilen oder
generell mit Punkten nur als lufthanser
Senator buchen den Status muss man
sicher arbeiten den habe ich jetzt seit
paar Jahren inne und so hatte ich die
Möglichkeit den Flug zu buchen dazu muss
man aber sagen dass nur weil man Senator
ist es nicht heißt dass man ihn
automatisch buchen kann man muss dann
immer wieder anrufen gucken dass
Verfügbarkeiten gibt also die Chance
dass man es trotzdem kriegt ist
vielleicht 5% wir hat den Glück ich habe
paar Telefonate gemacht ja also super
schwer ist meistens immer ausgebucht
weil natürlich Leute die den vollen
Preis bezahlen immer bevorzugt werden
ist natürlich klar und dann haben wir
noch ungefähr neben den Meilen wobei ich
mich da wirklich Frage wer bezahlt den
15 000 € dafür das ist ja wahnsinn ich
bin mir sicher dass alle anderen
Passagiere die hier in der Launch sitzen
und bei uns im fliegerwahen den ven
Preis gezahlt haben okay ja gut ja und
das waren so ungefähr 200000 Meilen pro
Person plus noch Steuern und Gebühren in
Höhe von ca 700
€ ja also jetzt habt das also auch sehr
viele Meilen ne mus sagen so viele
Meilen habe ich glaube ich in meinem
ganzen Leben noch nicht ausgegeben
deswegen müssen wir uns hier mal beim
Jonas bedanken dass er das möglich
gemacht hat dass ich hier so ein cooles
Video drehen konnte also vielen Dank
noch mal war auf jeden Fall echt geil
und eine Top Erfahrung für mich ger und
ja auch weil wir jetzt noch länger
unterwegs waren war das noch mal krasser
als die Emirates first natürlich ne war
schon echt sehr sehr luxuriöses reisen
luxusp muss man sagen ne also völlig
verrückt crazy hier gibt's auf jeden
Fall auch wieder ein leckeres Menü ich
bin eigentlich die ganze Zeit nur am
Essen ja so sieht das aus alak Cesar
salad hier unten noch andere Gerichte
Gerstensuppe Schweizer Käse von D wier
und es gibt aber auch ein ganzes Menü
wir haben jetzt hier mal die
käsekurketten da oben bestellt da ist
eine riesen Portion
angekommen das lassen wir uns jetzt noch
schmecken und eine Sache muss ich noch
sagen als ich verabschiedet wurde kam
noch ein Flugbilder zu mir der meinte er
hat das First Class Emirates Video
gesehen und der hat mir noch ein paar
Sachen geschenkt und zwar habe ich da
wohl gesagt dass ich so gerne Bier
trinke jetzt habe ich einfach eine
Auswahl an Schweizer Bieren und ich
glaube auch japanisches Bier also
wirklich extrem aufmerksam vielen vielen
Dank noch mal falls Sie das sehen habe
ich mich ser drüber gefreut und noch
irgendwie so ein Gesichtsspray so jetzt
werde ich schon wieder dum angeguckt
[Musik]
tschüss so wir sitzen jetzt im nächsten
Flieger jetzt geht's weiter nach Berlin
und das hört nicht auf ne jetzt hat hier
wieder das das von eben so eine Karte
geschickt das ist ja ganz
verrückt also noch sch Schokolade oh
mein Gott ich bin endlich zu Hause wir
haben jetzt 4R 0 in Japan ist es jetzt
schon 13 Uhr das heißt ich habe vom
Hotel bis hier in meine Wohnung 30
Stunden gebraucht und ich habe nicht
viel geschlafen zwei Stunden vielleicht
ich bin echt platt ich hoffe das Video
hat Euch gefallen es hat sich gelohnt
bestimmt ein richtig langes Video
geworden abonniert auf jeden Fall den
Kanal l no noch oben da ich wünsche euch
jetzt eine gute Nacht und ich schlafe
einfach morgen ohne Wecker aus mir
scheißegal haut rein Leute ciao